There are some things human beings aren’t
meant to know, and it’s the sworn duty of
The SCP Foundation to discover and contain
such information.
But sometimes, knowledge is discovered that
shakes even the Foundation itself to its very
core.
One such discovery occurred on April 28th,
2016 – the night that SCP – 2935 made
itself known to Foundation personnel.
To this day, the exact nature of SCP – 2935
is a mystery that even the Foundation’s
brightest minds can’t completely understand.
Everything we know about SCP – 2935 today
comes from three doomed missions into the
anomalous zone’s interior.
This is the story of those infamous expeditions.
The nightmare began around 5:00 AM, when SCP
Foundation Site 81 in Bloomingdale, Indiana,
intercepted a distorted radio signal.
Communications personnel at the site traced
this strange signal back to the unincorporated
area of Joppa, Indiana, near US Interstate
70.
As is Foundation policy, a team of Field Agents
were dispatched to the location in order to
determine what they were dealing with.
However, rather than finding anything that
could logically produce such a signal, they
instead discovered a long abandoned cemetery.
The most recent death on any of the tombstones
was recorded as being over a hundred years
ago, all the way back in 1908.
On further investigation,
the Foundation discovered
an unmapped limestone cave opening beneath
the cemetery and when they sent a drone into
the depths of the cave, it appeared to quickly
exit out the other side of the cave.
But something wasn’t right.
The area that the drone was observing appeared
consistent with the landscape from which it’d
entered, but now it looked somehow…greyer.
It lacked the color and life of the place
it’d just come from.
The grass was dead.
There were no trees, no shrubs, no animals
or birds in the sky.
They weren’t looking at our world.
They were looking at a strange reflection
of our world on the other side of the cave.
In fact, it wasn’t a cave at all – it
was a passageway between two dimensions.
It was SCP – 2935.
Just then they were able to unscramble the
distorted transmission they’d been receiving.
It went as follows:
“This is an automated emergency broadcast
from the SCP Foundation and your national
government.
One or more of our sites is experiencing a
communication breakdown,
likely due to a containment
breach of unknown magnitude.
All citizens are ordered to stay in their
homes as containment teams work to secure
the breach.
This message will broadcast from April 20th,
2016 until—”
At that point, the message would cut and repeat,
as it had been for eight straight days.
The message’s source?
Site 81.
But not this Site 81.
The SCP Foundation was receiving an emergency
distress signal from themselves in another
dimension – a bizarre event that even the
Foundation had never experienced before.
The Field Agents were
terrified by the implications
of what they’d just heard and contacted
Site 81 Command to request additional units.
The Foundation wished to fully understand
this anomaly as quickly as possible, due to
the potential threat it could pose towards
the Foundation, so they dispatched Mobile
Task Force Epsilon-13, codenamed “Manifest
Destiny”, to perform the first of three
manned missions into the heart of the anomalous
zone.
The first exploratory mission into SCP – 2935
was codenamed “Gauntlet”, and consisted
of a four-man team fitted with full hazmat
suits and direct video and audio links to
mission command.
The team was led by a Field Operative known
only as Agent Juno.
His subordinates were Agents Kael, Devon,
and Underwood.
Their directive was to gather samples and
survey the area positioned directly around
the insertion point, meaning the other cave
mouth of SCP – 2935.
The mission only lasted about an hour, but
what they saw in there would stay with these
men for the rest of their lives.
After a fifteen-minute trek through the cave,
Manifest Destiny arrived in the mirror dimension
where they were struck by the eerie silence
of a place that seemed identical and yet so
different from their home dimension.
The first observation they made was the total
absence of all living vegetation.
Trees, grass, weeds, everything – it was
all dead.
On orders from their superiors back in the
original dimension – that we’ll refer
to from here on as Dimension Prime – Manifest
Destiny headed deeper into the mirror dimension
of SCP – 2935.
They travelled two kilometers without detecting
a single sign of plant or animal life.
Not even insects.
Eventually, they came upon a farm house with
two cars parked outside.
With authorization from Command, Manifest
Destiny breached the house and headed inside.
Agent Kael confirmed that there was still
power flowing to the building, as the lighting
appeared to work just fine, but they came
upon a horrifying discovery in the house’s
dining room: Three adult corpses, two female
and one male, were seated at the table.
A fourth corpse, that of a male child, was
sprawled out on the ground nearby.
If the death of what looked to be an entire
family wasn’t awful enough, the Manifest
Destiny team noticed a number of other alarming
details.
There were no signs of decomposition on the
bodies, nor did there appear to be any obvious
cause of death.
The family’s last meal was still on the
table – Chicken, mashed potatoes, and green
beans.
While the food looked cold and stale, there
was no evidence of rot or spoiling.
The team found an opened newspaper dated April
19th, 2016, illustrating that the family may
have died a full eight days before the discovery.
In Dimension Prime, decay would already be
well underway by that point, yet here, there
wasn’t even a smell.
Instead, everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust.
Command requested that Manifest Destiny collect
samples of the food as well as hair, skin,
and fluids from the corpses for further study.
Small electronics like smart phones were also
taken from the bodies.
Agent Devon turned on the television in the
living room, and found that, while most stations
were now running test signals, the shopping
channel was still live.
Well the feed was live at least.
Both hosts sat in front of the cameras, dead,
but perfectly preserved.
The date on the screen read April 28th, 2016,
suggesting that the times of Dimension Prime
and the Mirror Dimension were exactly the
same.
In fact everything seemed the same, the only
difference between the two dimensions being
that some kind of mysterious apocalyptic event
had occurred in the last eight days in SCP
– 2935’s Mirror Dimension, but exactly
what had happened, or how, remained a mystery.
When Manifest Destiny exited the farm house,
they once again remarked on the lack of all
signs of life around them.
At this point, the team returned to the insertion
point of SCP – 2935, but were instructed
to remain in the Mirror Dimension while additional
units joined them inside.
Manifest Destiny swelled to sixteen members,
with the notable addition of Agent Roy as
the new commanding field officer.
The team split into two groups of eight, and
Agent Roy and his men infiltrated the Mirror
Dimension’s Site 81 while Agent Juno’s
detachment attempted to access the base’s
off-site deep storage servers.
This second expedition was codenamed “Overland”,
and led the Foundation’s Field Agents even
deeper into the terrifying mystery of SCP
– 2935.
Accessing the site was easy for Roy’s detachment.
It seemed there were relatively few cars on
the road at the time of the mysterious Extinction
Event.
In the distance, fires still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that looked to have
just dropped out of the sky.
Agent Roy and his team, like all SCP Foundation
personnel, were fitted with vitals trackers,
and they assumed that the distress signal
that started this whole thing could have been
triggered by the deaths of every member of
the Foundation at once in the Mirror Universe.
Once inside Site 81, they realized that assumption
was probably right.
Going door to door in the administrative wing,
they found the perfectly preserved corpses
of everyone they knew to be stationed there
in Dimension Prime.
People without a doubt were still alive in
their universe.
Samples from the corpses that the Foundation
would later study even confirmed the reason
that the bodies were perfectly preserved:
The corpses had experienced complete and sudden
death on a cellular level, and even the bacteria
that would typically take
part in the decomposition
process had died with it.
In SCP – 2935, death was total and absolute
across all types of life forms.
As Agent Roy’s team ventured further into
the bowels of Site 81, they
made another unsettling
discovery - their own corpses, in roughly
the spots they had been inside Dimension Prime’s
Site 81 eight days prior.
Some of the Foundation’s top scientists,
including the esteemed Dr. Bright, were also
found dead inside the facility.
In an attempt to see just how far this unexplained
phenomenon stretched, Agent Roy’s team decided
to inspect the containment cells – where
they found that all the Mirror Universe SCPs,
including SCP – 2996, were dead.
In his desperation to find some kind of exception
to the Extinction Event, Agent Roy revealed
a terrifying secret to the rest of his team:
SCP – 682, the immortal, misanthropic lizard,
and one of the deadliest creatures known to
the SCP Foundation, was contained at this
very facility, right below them.
Could it have something to do with what was
going on here?
They descended into its containment facility
to discover an even more unsettling truth.
SCP – 682, the unkillable anomaly, floated
dead in its tank Death truly made no exceptions
within SCP – 2935.
Agent Roy’s team left the site and rendezvoused
with Agent Juno’s team to send their research
and back to Dimension Prime using automated
drones.
Both teams remained in the Mirror Dimension
for another manned operation,
codenamed “Nineteen,”
they had no idea it would be their final mission.
As they descended deeper into the facility,
passing more dead SCPs they discovered one
final clue.
Based on the last activity of the Foundation
servers, the event occurred at roughly 3:00
AM.
While underground in SCP – 2935’s Site
81, the team accidentally activated the base’s
on-site nuclear weapon – a failsafe meant
to be detonated in the case of an emergency
containment breach.
Due to the base’s failsafe protocols, every
member of the Manifest Destiny team was locked
and sealed inside Site 81.
They, along with everything else, were incinerated
in the nuclear blast.
Once again, the Mirror Universe inside of
SCP – 2935 was lifeless.
But that isn’t where this ends.
When the automated drones returned out of
the SCP – 2935 cave to the Field Operatives
in Dimension Prime, they were in for their
own horrifying discovery.
None of the footage or information gathered
from SCP – 2935 illuminated how or why the
Extinction Event occurred.
Everyone and everything simply dropped dead
at the exact same moment.
Nobody was aware, nobody was prepared.
Death came suddenly and silently, and none
were spared.
All the Foundation on Dimension Prime were
left with was a message from one of the agents
from Manifest Destiny, Agent Keller.
His final message was: “I don't have any
answers.
I don't think there are any.
I'll do this one thing, and hope that fixes
it.
Seal it shut.
You've got to lock it in here with us.
I'm sorry.”
The Foundation were at first confused by this,
until they discovered a final encrypted audio
log buried in the files recovered from the
Mirror Universe’s Site 81.
It was a message from Keller himself, but
not the Keller from Universe Prime.
In this message, Keller described the Foundation
in the Mirror Universe receiving the exact
same distorted transmission that they did
a few days earlier from a cave in Joppa.
When he and the others were dispatched inside,
they discovered the same lifeless, post-Extinction
Event world that was now so familiar to Foundation
Command.
But there was a key difference: This wasn’t
the Mirror Dimension they’d just been studying,
but a third, entirely different dimension.
In his haunting final words, Mirror Dimension
Keller admits that whatever caused the event
in that third dimension – an entity that
Mirror Dimension Keller believed was the spectre
of Death itself – had followed him back
into his world, and history had repeated itself.
SCP – 2935 was the passageway through which
absolute death could pass from dimension to
dimension, and our dimension was the next
in line.
The deaths of Manifest Destiny may have saved
our entire universe, as anyone passing back
through the cave had the potential to bring
Death itself back with them.
The Foundation decided, in the end, to follow
Keller’s advice.
They sealed the entrance to SCP – 2935 with
concrete, and now keep it under constant watch,
since what waits behind the barrier is an
entity even they have no power to stop if
it ever got through.
After all, it had killed them all before,
or at least another version of them.
What’s one more dimension on the pile?
While it may now just seem like a simple slab
of concrete under an abandoned cemetery, this
is why SCP – 2935 might just be the most
dangerous SCP of all.